[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis championne de france je sais
vous me regardez vous vous dites pas
avec ses jambes tout souvent longues
heures je sais pas comment ça se fait si
elle est championne de quelque chose
qu'on n'a jamais entendu parler d'elle
non je suis championne de france dans
une catégorie bien plus accessible tout
le monde peut participer et en général
tout le monde participe sans trop le
vouloir
depuis l'été 2016 je suis championne de
france de cyber harcèlement pas parce
que merci beaucoup merci
alors c'est pas parce que j'ai participé
un jeu précis c'est parce que j'ai subi
j'ai subi un des plus impressionnants
cas de cyber harcèlement de france plus
de 40 mille commentaires menaçants
insultant violent en un peu plus d'un an
c'est un record et là vous vous dites
que j'aurais quand même mieux fait de
choisir le saut en longueur nan ça
aurait été moins éprouvant je travaille
sur internet
je fais des vidéos dans le monde virtuel
le monde virtuel où je montre mon vrai
visage où je parle avec ma vraie voix et
où je dis des choses que je pense
vraiment le monde virtuel qui est
presque comme ce monde là où vous me
voyez on respire le même air le monde
virtuel qui est à portée de main sur nos
téléphones portables où on passe
plusieurs heures par jour pour se
divertir ou pour travailler et donc
finalement on arrive pas tellement à se
passer puisque en france plus de 80% des
foyers ont un accès à internet
le monde virtuel qui est finalement
exactement comme ce monde là qu'on
appelle en opposition est la vraie vie
parce que finalement c'est ça la seule
différence entre le monde virtuel et le
non virtuel c'est qu'on peut pas se voir
avec nos yeux mais on va en revenir sur
mon record si ça vous dérange pas j'ai
pas volé ce titre j'aimerais qu'on en
parle un peu à quoi ça ressemble le
cyber harcèlement
alors si vous avez des enfants en bas
âge ou si vous êtes vous même très
souvent connectés il faut savoir que à
ça c'est pas bien méchant
qu'est ce que je disais oui si vous avez
des enfants qui vont bientôt vivre avec
leur époque est donc passé la plupart de
leur temps en ligne
il faut que vous sachiez que le s'est
excusé moi allô bonjour
en fait j'ai l'impression que j'ai pas
toute votre attention
je vous propose qu'on attende que ça
passe ça vous ça marche pas non je sais
vous savez ce qu'on va faire on va les
ignorer ça marche pas trop non plus
parce que je vois vos regards en fait
ils sont vraiment là alors que c'est moi
qui parle
ouais bah arreter là parce que même à
cette vitesse quarante mille menaces de
mort menace de viol et insultes ça peut
être très très long et puis c'est pas si
facile à ignorer finalement vous voulez
connaître le trajet de ces messages
alors de la pensée d'un vrai humain qui
a tapé ses messages sur son vrai clavier
par le monde virtuel pour arriver dans
ma vraie vie où mes vrais yeux ont lu
ses messages et où mon vrai cerveau les
a compris il n'existe pas deux mondes
virtuels tout ce qui se passe en ligne
se passe dans la vraie vie on va fermer
l'onglet moussavou déconcentre trop un
elle est fermée moi ça vous devez vous
demander ce que j'ai fait pour mériter
ça bon je me fais insulter
on est en france il ya des lois et c'est
vrai les menaces de mort de viol et les
insultes ça ne rentre pas dans ce qu'on
appelle la liberté d'expression l'injure
publique en france et passible de douze
mille euros damende je suis dans mon bon
droit je peux très bien aller porter
plainte contre fans de jul 60 x ptdr 22
ou hervé superman je sais rien sur ces
gens si ce n'est que peut-être leur
département de naissance je suis pas sûr
mais vous imaginez 40000 personnes dont
j'ai pas l'identité
comment est ce que c'est possible que
40000 personnes n'est pas mieux à faire
dans leur vraie vie que m'atteindre moi
dans ma vraie vie ça a commencé en était
2016 y avait les jeux olympiques de rio
potentiellement des tonnes de trucs très
intéressant à faire les épreuves de saut
en longueur par exemple c'est c'est fou
et puis c'est pas moi contre quarante
mille personnes
c'est moi contre une personne plus une
personne plus une personne plus une
personne qui est une personne peut être
compris la suite
j'ai pas le temps ni l'énergie ni les
moyens de porter plainte contre 40 mille
pseudonyme
vous avez déjà porté plainte contre eux
quelqu'un vous connaissez les démarches
administratives pour porter plainte
contre quelqu'un en france c'est très
long contre une personne donc imaginer
quarante mille personnes
bon j'ai pas envie de porter plainte
contre x parce que c'est pas x qui me
harcèle ses les vrais gens j'en viens à
me demander qui sont ses vrais gens et
comment c'est possible que 40000 vrais
gens ignorent la loi
est-ce que vous la connaissiez la loi
sur l'injure publique
bah non en fait moi non plus je vois
pourquoi je vous demande ça non j'ai dû
chercher cette loi quand ça m'est arrivé
donc j'imagine que si vous n'êtes jamais
fait agresser en ligne a pas de raison
que vous soyez au courant que l'injure
publique est passible de douze mille
euros damende ça s'apprend pas à l'école
non non à l'école on apprend à placer le
rhône sur une carte de france
on l'apprend le théorème de thalès et
puis on apprend les règles élémentaires
du vivre ensemble dans la société comme
le respect la tolérance la politesse et
puis on apprend aussi que nul n'est
censé ignorer la loi
donc dans un pays où on apprend à se
respecter et qui ignoraient la loi n'est
pas une excuse pour l'enfreindre
statistiquement il n'y a aucune chance
pour qu'une personne se fasse harcelé
par 40 milles 1
yes peut-être un petit problème avec
l'éducation
je vous vois vous vous demandez qu'est
ce que j'ai fait pour mériter ça est-ce
que j'ai pris publiquement parti dans le
débat pains au chocolat chocolatines bon
il ya la loi et à l'éducation
et puis il ya le contrôle social le
contrôle social c'est ce qui fait que
vous faites toujours la queue à la poste
et que vous dépassez pas tout le monde
pour pas passer pour un malotru c'est ça
qui fait que personne ne prend jamais la
dernière part de gâteau pour pas passer
pour un malpoli le contrôle social c'est
quand on fait attention à notre
comportement à cause du regard des gens
là dans ce cas là quarante mille
personnes ne respectent pas la loi qu'il
la connaisse ou non ils sont pas aidés
par l'éducation qui ne leur a pas donné
les clés et puis ils ont l'air d'être
complètement exemptes contrôle social et
même au contraire la dynamique de groupe
les pousse à continuer bas à temps si
machin l'a insulté et qu' il n'a pas été
puni c'est pas grave si moi je le fais
aussi j'ai bien conscience que ces gens
se sont pas ligués contre moi que c'est
pas une conspiration mais peu importe
c'est ça le harcèlement c'est une
accumulation d'agression et d' insulte à
l'égard de quelqu'un dans le temps dans
le but de lui nuire
ça marche bien ça marche bien on est
ligue et on n'est pas content et on crie
fort face à ça j'étais sur des sites sur
un site sur un réseau social et a
forcément une loi une politique des
règles donc forcément logiquement en
m'adressant aux modérateurs de ces
réseaux sociaux je devrais réussir à
obtenir au mieux la suppression des
comptes qui me harcèle au pire la
suppression des messages qui m'insultent
qui sont hors la loi mais tous les sites
et les réseaux sociaux répond de la même
chose ce n'est pas de ma faute
en fait moi je ne suis pas un média je
suis un diffuseur
donc je ne prends pas parti face à moi
je cherchais simplement des solutions
j'ai cherché réparation avec la loi j'ai
cherché de l'espoir dans l'éducation en
disant que mon exemple servir est
peut-être à quelque chose et puis j'ai
chercher du soutien et de la solidarité
avec les réseaux sociaux les médias
décidément je me serais sentie moins
seule moins isolés moins stigmatisés
j'avais envie au lieu d'entendre or
c'est pas la vraie vie ou attaquer les
ignorer non j'avais envie qu'on me dise
que ce que je vivais s'était pas normal
que j'avais des raisons d'en souffrir
j'avais envie de me retrouver avec le
visage plein de coups pour qu'on me
regarde on se dit oh là là il ya un
problème qu'est ce que ça vient on s'en
occupe
j'avais envie qu'on arrête de me dire
qu'il suffisait que je ferme les onglets
pour que les salles pub va mourir
disparaissent je me suis sentie
complètement désemparé bon il s'agit de
ma vie ça peut être la vie de n'importe
qui ça peut être votre vie
ça peut être la vie de vos enfants ça
peut être la vie de vos grands parents
s'ils aiment surfer c'est la vie
aujourd'hui de beaucoup d'adolescents
qui ont tenté de mettre fin à la leur et
puis quelque chose qui m'a frappé
moi aussi j'ai déjà fait des erreurs en
ligne
déjà envoyé un commentaire malveillants
et insultants à quelqu'un qui disait des
choses contre lesquelles j'étais
profondément et je me suis déjà dit que
parce que moi j'ai été engagé et j'avais
un vrai combat je défends des des
avancées sociales
j'avais le droit d'insulter quelqu'un
mais on peut pas vouloir changer les
comportements et les mentalités et
utiliser les mêmes armes que ceux qui
nous attaquent
on peut tous se faire harceler en ligne
mais on peut tous participé à un
harcèlement
même si c'est une fois même si s'est
noyé au milieu de quarante mille
personnes
même si nous on avait des très bonnes
raisons de le faire
si autant de gens sans se donner le mot
sans se liguer contre moi ou il impacte
aussi puissant et négatifs sur ma vie
imaginez l'impact de commentaires
positifs
si on réussit individuellement a généré
des vagues de haine
logiquement on devrait réussir
individuellement a généré des vagues
d'amour de soutien de bienveillance si
on accepte qu'une poignée de gens et ne
puisse avoir un tel impact sur la vie de
quelqu'un il faut prendre conscience
qu'une poignée de gens bienveillants
peuvent avoir un tel impact sur la vie
de quelqu'un on est maître de notre
impact
contrairement à ce qu'on a beaucoup
répété c'est pas plus facile d'insulter
en ligne manon regard des [ __ ] cécile
est remercie ces cinq lettres bim une
lettre de moi on a le pouvoir de changer
ça je me suis rendu compte dans ma
position parce que je suis pas la
première ni la dernière à me faire
harceler
mais je me suis rendu compte dans ma
position unique de cible de harcèlement
qu'il n'y a pas d'un côté les gens qui
harcèle au milieu les témoins et de
l'autre les gens qui soutiennent non il
ya ceux qui font partie du problème et
ceux qui font partie de la solution
alors je vous demande pas d'aller vous
battre dans une guerre qui n'est pas la
vôtre d'aller débattre avec des gens qui
ne sont pas d'accord avec vous je vous
demande pas de devenir des soldats du
bien je vous demande pas d'utiliser un
hashtag non
je vous propose juste de donner
l'exemple de prendre l'habitude de
communiquer votre satisfaction en ligne
votre amour
pourquoi pas ou juste votre présence de
commenter de laïcs et de mettre un pouce
bleus pour ceux qui ont la réf
et puis de laisser un commentaire
constructif même s'il est négatif
et puis si vous n'avez pas le temps un
emoji coeur suffira si on crie plus fort
notre satisfaction on n'entendra plus du
tout ceux qui crient leur haine ouvre à
trop de bruit c'est très important que
la bienveillance se réapproprient
l'espace de discussion en ligne
je vous ai toujours pas dit ce que
j'avais fait pour mériter ça nous le
savoir eh ben j'ai fait exactement ce
que je viens de faire devant vous ce
soir j'ai exprimé publiquement mon
opinion sur le harcèlement et si vous
venez de voir cette vidéo en ligne
n'hésitez pas à laisser un commentaire
ou un coeur merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]